so you write in the book about why
different people find this fixation on
the power differential
uh appealing
as a belief system uh so i'd love for
you to unpack that a little bit how did
this
gain so much currency and power it
gained power partly because if you are
an elect
you feel that you have a mission
you feel that you're seeing further than
most people who wouldn't like that you
have a sense of community with people
who are as on fire about these things as
you
but you know to tell you the truth a lot
of it is and i think we all feel this
way about certain things you feel
smarter than the average bear you see
further battling power differentials
you're the one who sees how important
that is and so there you go and you're
helping to save black people we have
progress in this country in that people
are so ashamed of being racist that's a
good thing if you're an elect then
you've got that covered because you have
devoted your whole heart and soul to
battling racism and supposedly saving
black people if you're black and you
fall for this it's different and it's
hard to talk about especially
for me
but
you can
fall for the victimhood mindset the
victimization mindset is something that
psychologists recognize as a human trait
it's not about black people it's human
there's a certain kind of person who
exaggerates their victimhood you can
only do it if your life is really pretty
much okay you exaggerate your victimhood
and you dismiss the victimhood of other
people and you derive your sense of
significance from you being a survivor
of this supposed victimization that's a
mindset we all know the tattletale we
all know the martyr black america has a
way of oding on that because
it's such a terrible history we've got
in this country treat it like animals
for hundreds of years and jim crow
slavery even talk about redlining and
then there are even things today
depending on how you feel about
microaggressions it can be hard to be
proud
of being black it's easy to fall for the
idea that being black is inferior what
do you do about that there are all sorts
of things one thing a black person might
do is to grab on to this idea that what
makes you special is that you are a
victim of this ongoing onslaught of
racism that you and your people deal
with every day i think all of us can
understand how that would be a tempting
way of processing the world if there's a
hole inside of you if there's a hole in
black america's soul and i think many
people if they didn't hear me saying it
would agree completely there is a hole
one way to fill it is to manufacture a
sense of victimhood and to build your
identity around your being a noble
survivor anybody would do that given
black people's history but that's what
it is and so white people and black
people in this elect religion end up
doing a kind of a dance white people
pretend to agree with this
characterization of what being black is
like black people give white people a
certain kind of power we absolve white
people of their sin to an extent but
none of this has anything to do
with black people having real problems
including racially conditioned systemic
racism type ones out in the real world
this little dance is like this cotillion
that people are having while the rest of
the world burns and i'm hoping to make
people realize that's what's going on
yes i i agree that
there are real fundamental problems and
let's work on those um as opposed to
monitoring someone's statement on social
media as if if you just got that right
then all would be well right
how that connects with this right yeah
exactly um so i'm going to share some uh
stories from my childhood to give you a
sense as to
my reaction and one reason why i i
believe that um what you're saying is so
important so i grew up one of the only
asian kids in my school my school is
predominantly white um there were two
black kids um there were you know two
asian kids like that kind of school um
and so it was very tough to be uh black
it was tough to be asian
um the culture was somewhat different it
was like the 80s and 90s and so you know
like you remember like there wasn't
exactly a surplus of
i remember this well yeah yeah
um and so i got taunted for being asian
all the time um and the the black kids
had it tough too jewish kid had it tough
um and so there is like this sense that
i have from my upbringing um that
you know like
uh that racism
uh is something
um that
uh i think
is
uh
present
um in a lot of people
in some form in terms of their like
attitudes towards different people um
and that
because of that i i don't have any
thoughts that's like oh we're going to
be in a place where you don't notice
that i'm asian like i mean that that
would be ridiculous
yeah and so then the question really is
how do we try and uh make concrete
changes in the real world i'm like less
interested in policing people's thoughts
or even to some extent uh their
statements
um and i'm more concerned about trying
to move things around in the real world
that will make
um a difference uh make things positive
i will also comment
that if you were a non-white kid in that
era of 80s and 90s like blackness was
the only cool way to not be white
if you know what i mean which is one of
the reasons why you had all of these
these hip hoppings yes right
you know and so i had baggy jeans uh you
know like the whole thing and there were
a lot of white kids in the suburbs who
bought the food
that was like the
um like uh especially in my case as an
asian
boy
i felt like my masculinity was always in
question there's that trope yes and so
then and and so
uh you know um black culture was a way
it's like oh this is what non-white
masculinity is right
so
let's i remember this yeah yeah it's um
and i'm 70s i'm a little bit older and
um i got some trouble for being black i
grew up in very similar environments
there were two asians that i remember in
my
my private school there were some black
people but it was white people who
called the tune and i'm from i can't
believe how old i'm getting i'm 56 i'm
from even before hip-hop and so in the
70s there wasn't yet this idea that
people who weren't black could pretend
to be that hadn't quite happened yet and
so the white kids were just being white
if anything they liked hard rock which i
never understood and the black kids well
you dealt with stuff and what i don't
get about today
is that i'm supposed to say
you hurt me by saying something or by
not saying something a generation before
me black person wouldn't have been hurt
but i am now i feel like that is giving
into something i'm saying that i'm in
the down position i'm pretending a
certain vulnerability there is i would
never want to do that there is some of
that where it's like um you know when i
was a kid and someone uh called me like
[ __ ] or something be confused maybe hurt
the rest of it um you know
at a certain point you feel like the
natural reaction uh instead of screaming
injustice on social media would be just
[ __ ] you
[Laughter]
you can't hurt me yeah
you know
um but no that's not the current idea
and so yeah if somebody even called me
the n word whoever it was chances are
there'd be something kind of wrong with
them and my idea would be if you did
that i'm looking down upon you just who
were you and now i'm going to go do
whatever i was doing but no i'm supposed
to you know jump onto a bed and cry into
the pillow i was told to go back to my
country like you know uh not that long
ago but the person who said it was
clearly mentally ill so like
[Laughter]
right yeah go back to where you came
from
how stupid is that yeah so you know but
like person was you know like uh you
know they needed help so
[Laughter]
so there is um
so
this movement has
uh has some currency
um and you say that look this is
actually counterproductive for black
people in the real world and you have a
few examples in your book that i thought
were very very powerful and important so
on one hand it's like hey let's try and
modern moderate people's or uh you know
monitor people's behaviors and
statements and then you were like look
it's actually hurting black kids
right now because here are the real
issues and one one you put out there was
trying to
improve the discipline and behavior of
middle school kids and if you go and say
hey look like i'm not going to enforce
standards because
uh like these black kids cannot be
expected to conform to behave or conform
to these standards you know like that's
actually a profound disservice to the
kids themselves yeah and that's one of
these things
there's a meme out there which is that
black boys are suspended for violence
disproportionately
not because in a great many schools
black boys are more violent than the
others now just let that drop you're not
even supposed to say it nevertheless as
unpleasant as the fact is
it's true
it couldn't be because of that it must
be because of bias
now the way to look at it is to pull the
camera back why are the black boys so
often more violent and poverty has a lot
to do with violence fatherlessness has a
lot to do with violence and everybody
knows that there is a lot of
fatherlessness and many
underserved
again and again any big city that you
live in probably journalists at the big
newspaper if there still is one have
gone out trying to find this bias and
didn't find it study after study and yet
there's this idea that there's this bias
against black boys and the three b's are
seen as somehow being some kind of truth
like alliteration is truth and the thing
is if teachers hold back and don't
suspend black boys for violence which
has happened what happens is that big
surprise the schools get more violent
the grade point average of the school
goes down and i think some people are
thinking well good because those white
and asian kids in the school they
deserve that violence because it's going
to get back at all the things that have
been done for black no no no because you
have to remember that fact that
everybody knows that a disproportionate
number of black kids go to all black
schools it's just hurting other black
kids my kids who are being hurt nobody
wants to talk about it and so there's a
kind of person and it's not that i think
this person knows all of this and
insists on soldiering ahead all of us go
through life looking through a little a
little hole but there's a certain kind
of person who stands up there in a suit
talking about the bias against black
boys and everybody claps and they're not
thinking about the fact that if those
boys aren't disciplined
other black boys and girls are being
beaten up in these schools along with
often the teachers it should matter
yes uh you had a another
problem which you called yale or jail
uh and and what you're suggesting is
that look uh it's not that if you don't
go to
uh yale then all of a sudden there's
nothing waiting for you but uh you know
ruined
you know that that there's like a
multitude of you're on the highway
that's right
of these other
opportunities and that sometimes putting
uh students in environments that aren't
the best fit for them actually ends up
hurting their ambitions i think you
cited a study where um you have
fewer scientists because they if they go
into some of these
courses um
uh and
uh majors that they they uh end up um
being pushed out of them whereas if they
were in another environment then they
might actually finish and then become
that scientist yep you see it again and
again and you know there's some counter
studies that are being done that are
nibbling at the edges of some of the
specific claims of that work but the
larger truth is painfully obvious and
not refuted which is that if a kid is
admitted to a school where everything is
going to happen faster than they're
prepared for they're not going to do as
well they're not going to have a good
time they're going to leave disenchanted
and that's just there and no study can
eat away at that there have been some
things said about stem in particular
stem is one of many subjects that people
can major in in school about which
nothing has been said and what it means
is that to insist that you have a
certain percentage of for example black
kids at elite schools and that you're
going to do it by lowering standards for
most of the black kids so that you can
have that number ends up hurting the
black kids and there are studies that
you aren't shown i don't think anybody's
going whoo-hoo-ha-ha and hiding them but
when black kids like that for example in
california when racial preferences were
banned 25 years ago started going to
perfectly solid but not flagship
university of california schools they
did better kids at uc san diego who
would have been admitted to berkeley or
ucla and kind of treaded water
did excellently at ucsd you would think
that that would have been on the
headline of every newspaper in the
country nobody cared because what you
were supposed to talk about was the
racism of banning racial preferences and
that just won't do a lot of black kids
who are admitted to the selective
schools would have a much better time
and have much better grades this also
goes for law schools if they were
admitted to the second tier but
excellent schools and i think some
people are thinking why should they
settle for the second tier but there are
all these people teaching and working at
these second tier schools who think of
themselves as being part of excellent
institutions what's so horrible about
them why does everybody have to go to
the top 32 and so this is a conversation
we don't have because what we're
supposed to talk about is solely
racism racism racism we must make these
kids welcome but often they'd feel more
welcome at a school where they were
being taught at a pace that they could
keep up with
the conversation
[Music]
you